Ever wonder just what kind of weird stuff
is buried in the Netflix catalog?
You could spend all day scrolling around in
search of the strange, but we've got you covered.
Let's take a look at some of the most bizarre
films you can find on Netflix.
Wetlands
Based on the novel bya Charlotte Roche, this
movie features unrealistically massive amounts
of bodily fluids to tell the stark, true,
and riveting story of an 18-year-old woman
coming of age.
While exploring the human body in an act of
rebellion against her mother, she finds herself
trying to rekindle a love between her divorced
parents while falling for her male nurse — a
man she met after a shaving accident gone
terribly wrong.
Hard to be a God
The Guardian called Hard to be a God "a monumental,
and monumentally mad film."
Based on the novel of the same name by Arkady
and Boris Strugatsky, it's set in what looks
like a medieval sci-fi Russia — but on a
different planet that looks remarkably like
Earth.
There, two competing factions called "Blacks"
and "Greys" are at war.
The peasants are disfigured, ugly and stuck
in copious amounts of blood and mud for eternity.
The film forces its audience to ponder another
world, like ours, where life is, and has been,
much worse.
Upstream Color
This is a movie about a parasite that passes
between humans, pigs, and orchids.
Surprisingly, that's not the weirdest thing
about it.
A man known as "The Thief" manages to implant
a worm in a woman called Kris that allows
her to mentally communicate with pigs — which
also allows her to come to grips with her
very dysfunctional relationship with her boyfriend
Jeff.
It prompted Slate critic Forrest Wickman to
write, "I just saw Upstream Color … What
just happened?"
A question we're still trying to answer.
God of Cookery
This film about the rise, fall, and rise again
of a Chinese chef tickles your funny bone
while playing to a very specific audience.
Variety describes it as "an entertaining,
often very funny blend of high-energy Cantonese
comedy and culinary kung fu."
But if you're not a fan of both cooking and
martial arts, don't worry, because it's hilarious
and daring enough for any movie lover to enjoy.
3 Headed Shark Attack
If you looked at the title of this movie and
thought it screamed for actor Danny Trejo,
then you're in luck: you'll find him in a
fishing boat full of guns and ammo, beheading
a three-headed shark.
The plot is straightforward enough: the mutant
creature in the title attacks a ship and it
won't stop until it's eaten everyone, while
the passengers use anything they can to fight
it off.
What's not to love?
"Oh, shoot!"
It's like Jaws, plus two more heads, and also
terrible.
But in the very best way.
Now what could possibly top that?
What about a movie called...
The ABCs of Death
What if you hired 26 directors­, one for
each letter of the alphabet?
Then what if you tasked each of them with
crafting a short film that needed only to
fall into a certain runtime and follow a narrative
built around death?
That's exactly what producers Ant Thompson
and Tim League did with this experimental
anthology film.
Watch it for the cinematography — and for
some seriously boundary pushing butt jokes.
He Never Died
The tagline to He Never Died gets right to
the point: "It's hard to live when you can't
die."
Actor, singer, author and bicycle shorts enthusiast
Henry Rollins plays Jack.
Jack's a kind of mysterious anti-hero whose
listless drift through middle age is upended
when his teenage daughter is kidnapped.
Rollins plays Jack as a subtle homage to Arnold
Schwarzenegger's Terminator, which is probably
the least weird thing about the film.
"Probably just gonna go kill another room
full of people."
" You are?!"
"Probably…"
"Come on!!"
Daemonium
Unless it's coming from Guillermo del Toro,
a little bit of fantasy horror goes a long
way.
Where del Toro enthralled audiences with Pan's
Labyrinth, Argentinian director Pablo Pares'
Daemonium opts to go full-out weird at the
expense of plot, pacing, and character development.
That's cool, though, because instead Daemonium
delivers a bizarre mix of demons, wizards,
and martial arts action that flirts with your
eyes like a splash of drain cleaner.
Just about every ten minutes, Daemonium goes
from bad to badass to bad acid and back again,
an endless carousel completely unfettered
by logic.
Just sit back and enjoy the ride.
The Scribbler
What if you were a killer and didn't know
it?
That's the question asked by The Scribbler,
which follows a woman named Suki with multiple
personalities living in an apartment building
sanctioned for psychiatric patients.
One by one, the women in the building start
dying, allegedly jumping to their deaths.
The movie is told within the framework of
Suki's interrogation by the police after the
fact, giving it a weird sense of altered chronology
and an unreliable narrative — after all,
it's a story being told by a crazy woman.
So yeah, it gets way weird as the story progresses.
Superpowers, insanity, a totally freaky God
machine — all hidden behind the closed doors
of a psychiatric institute.
It boasts some pretty sleek visuals and a
unique story line, if nothing else.
Night Watch/Day Watch
Before he made his English-language debut
with 2008's Wanted or his follow-up, 2012's
Abraham Lincoln: Vampire Hunter, Timur Bekmambetov
wrote and directed the double feature of Night
Watch and Day Watch.
These two sci-fi films simply don't follow
any of the norms of Hollywood blockbusters
— and that's a good thing.
Probably.
The dreamlike dissonance of these movies is
enough to make you question your own sanity,
since the only constant rule in the Day/Night
Watch universe is "make it shiny."
All the plot threads about alternate dimensions
and vampires and ancient forces do come together
into a sort of coherent story, but it's a
hard weave to figure out.
Good luck!
Deathgasm
Once upon a time, someone watched Scott Pilgrim
vs. the World and thought, "This would be
a lot better with more heavy metal and naked
women, and maybe someone, like, beats up a
demon with a sex toy."
It's a thought we've all had at some point.
You're having that thought right now.
Admit it.
Anyway, whatever caused it to happen, Deathgasm
is now an irretrievable piece of the world.
It's out there, unable to be undone.
So what is the film supposedly about?
Well, it follows four teenagers who start
a metal band in their garage and inadvertently
play a song that unleashes hell on their quiet
suburban neighborhood.
To save the town, they have to pretty much
kill everyone in it.
New Zealand's been giving us some great quirky
comedies lately, like What We Do In The Shadows,
and Deathgasm is certainly part of the gang.
Even if it's the weird kid that hangs out
in the back acting like a spaz.
Zombeavers
A movie called Zombeavers featuring singer
John Mayer and comedian Bill Burr should get
your attention.
"Hey man, you see that deer up there?"
"Yeah. I see it."
"I don't think you do…"
Especially when the plot follows the fallout
from a toxic waste spill that sends a swamp
full of zombie beavers to attack a gang of
helpless teenagers.
According to RogerEbert.com, "Zombeavers is
exactly what it sounds like: A stoner-friendly
horror-comedy about undead beavers."
Finally, truth in advertising.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!